hello everyone
scp-049 here playing the ultimate doom
now as you may or may not know this is a
mod or the original term called brutal
do now this version comes with multiple
enhancements for example mouse look you
can aim with your mouse which you
couldn't any originals multiple graphics
enhancements a better hard for more
modern displays as I'm so fortunate to
be playing on right now and you can
download multiple other add-ons which to
be fair I could have actually put in
that I decided not to because I wanted
to keep it as modern as possible but
also as faithful to the original as
possible now one of the main differences
between brutal doom and the original is
obviously instead of a pistol you have
an assault rifle and if you aim at the
head you can actually take down most
things considerably quicker than the
original now this campaign is called
knee-deep in the Dead which
was the first-ever chapter of the dude I
don't even think the core derivative is
look so many different versions of of
the campaign as you could see whenever I
was selecting my campaign there was
three other ones now I'm just thinking
where I need to go memory serves is
indeed now this is not really like any
other modern first-person shooter as
it's extremely fast paced there is no
emphasis on the likes of cover based
shooting also I thought I think I should
mention it's not really something that
you would expect me to play if I realize
this most of my games are medical doctor
thing that's fair enough
but I really did want a break from all
of the drudgery and say meanness for
lack of a better term so I decided to
plan on classic and whilst you probably
won't know this I am quite a big fan of
modern games and as everyone as well
there is only doom going to be released
soon I think in the next month so I
thought it was fitting if I played the
original now I'm not sure how long this
series is going to go on for
it's probably going to be lit up in two
different parts
the policies of my commentary is a bit
lacking I do have to concentrate quite a
bit in shooting zombies and imps that's
another new feature abrooke will do some
of the attacks of the minions have been
edited for example the imps in the
original doom never bounced they never
jumped at you once they they do this and
it's quite annoyed
I've chosen now the medium difficulty
because from what I've heard brutal doom
is hard enough as it is and I don't
really want to make this insane even
though I do to challenge so it was
important to try and use the barrels to
your advantage for a number of reasons
it saves on ammunition as ammunition
sometimes is quite scarce one of the
downsides of doom is of course I'm going
to be using the shotgun primarily as
it's the most prevalent among horse and
the most powerful not quite sure I'm
expected to go here but that's another
feature of brutal doom that I really
like and that is you can execute people
as I'm sure you see earlier on
also whenever you kill a zombie there is
a chance I'm not sure that chance is
based on whether you shoot them in the
leg they just love fully dead but they
actually stay on the ground writhing in
pain and you have to put them out of
your misery
out of their misery apologies again I'm
concentrating so there's just so many
additions that make this familiar but
also I like the chainsaw I'm quite do I
like that ok looks like I'm not going to
get the trains on okay so I'm sorry I
completely lost my train of thought and
I just get the map here you just tell me
what I need to go okay one of the
unfortunate side effects of brutal doom
is they have added clip sizes to your
weapons which is oh there's a switch I
didn't even see that
apologies I think you know out of
backtrack that's right and then right
again oh yes here we go
this seems to be on the right path
step back beautiful a chainsaw find some
meat good
well that's provided me with a more
vicious kind of so I'm just trying to
think why I'm supposed to go here well
this is going to be fun anyway as I was
saying the chainsaws provided me with
them all viable melee option if I do run
out of ammunition which in do sometimes
is very likely again the poison barrels
always help and that's the end of level
2 I could just get rid of these
alright moving down that no nuclear
plant finished now this beginning levels
really are just incredibly easy I'm sure
you can tell ok now I do have to be
careful as these are the this is the
first introduction of the pink diamonds
they're not really a threat from long
range
but in melee range yeah quite invisible
demons here as well
quite literally invisible I'm not really
sure how I'm supposed to kill them has
to be something there has to be a
strategy I can use there's also strategy
ok so
using the poison barrels to my effect
again
now
that nujol attack never fails to be
annoying finish him up I think if I go
up to the right here that's a lot of
shotgun zombies
I do forget some of the names of the
enemies sometimes I'm not really sure if
I should run in you I think I would have
got mauled if I'm a ninja health is
dangerously low at this point
I'm trying to shoot every barrel I can
visible I think you can see their eyes
their eyes are visible that doesn't
really help me at this point as there is
a lot of glowing things in these maps
interesting sidenote Brigadoon is a lot
little gory than the original game as
well which I love I like blood it makes
me feel safe glad to get more health
I'd shoot some of the barrels of the
distance now should have dodged it up
that's another new addition
flaming zone it's always wise to never
wait okay
good being careful not to fall off you
Oh crumbs well that was stupid on my
part
oh well okay let's try and see who can
not die here you have to be careful
health good right now that I have the
blue key
I can backtrack and enter other
locations first of all I'm really
wanting in that mega sphere I think this
is the way
well this looks to be the right way more
health as well
good and this should be it
and it is sorry not mega sphere soul
sphere not really up in my do
terminology has a plate right now I can
go in here not welcome it off where this
whole sphere there to be careful if I
run in there I am will be to be smoothly
by shotguns exploding barrel always
works
you must every time I'd lie down where
he came from
snuck up on Emeril what I can was a good
idea
quickly check seems to be clear plenty
of Health run on to the next level
toxiel refinery furnished command
control ok now I think this is where the
game start to get starting it's slightly
more challenging
more enemies more diverse enemies and
more strategic positions harder to reach
places and in longer range places as a I
can more effectively a man I again okay
going to try and they're full of them
okay I'm not shown what happened
laughing one of the Imps actually
treated that chain reaction either way
good this is another scenario where
reloading is unfortunate one that was
lucky
bucket loader awesome from I really have
making up a lot of Americanisms from
playing video games awesome I like it I
like it
did not expect that well that was rather
stupid note to self don't shoot barrel
when it's in front of your face
Jane gums quite me although he uses the
same MO as the pistol and it can burn
through the elbow almost 20 times faster
so you're better only using it the
emergencies likewise with a rocket
launcher only for special occasions
shall come an assault rifle for normal
level clearing or ammunition so if not
I've edition I'm heavy
I have a lot of armor now so I have
really no excuse when it comes to losing
if I lose this level I am going to be
very angry I'm going to quit in a rage I
suppose you could call it a rage quit
that's another Americanism I've picked
up I don't know one going for those
packets of health I really really don't
need them now
back home I don't want to the pipe is
not good morning
try to use the girls again very poorly
timed as was that door closed
it really is lucky that I have so much
health and armor because if I didn't I
think I would have been dead by now
the closed spaces really are not my
friend again might need to use a nap
suit if I could not die before I nail
the games that I played
I have been quite relaxed I think this
game will be the exception as it is
quite stressful
personally for me apologies of this
episodes anyone know offenses cost I am
just find it hard sometimes to maintain
composure when faced with Hellspawn I
hope you understand the yellow key
I was like sneaking up on zombies very
very satisfied well that was just
needless violence really wasn't it
I think about jump in wait
I'm just going to go back and get some
more ammo because I think I'm running
quite low
shotgun voice and you pull okay
all right him come on control cleared